if you recall last time well last week
tuesday friday what did we spend our
time on I'll give you a bit like a hint
it started with a heck of a lot of these
one weekend okay very good we looked at
graphing on the complex plane some kind
of expression like say oh I don't know
what was only looked at something like
this remember the exact example actually
I don't remember okay so there's a set
of points there's a set of Zins that
satisfy this equation and you control
them oh don't you draw for this one what
are you gonna have the origin a hollow
circle hole in a circle there and then
there's going to be a start of an arc do
you remember it's a ray that goes off
how to describe it it's going to be in
the second quadrant okay and 2.3 is what
is that degrees again hundred and twenty
okay so you've gone from zero to 90 and
then you go a little bit more and then
there's your there's the locus of points
that all satisfy the supreme okay now
you may remember I think we ended you
might need to help me on this precisely
I think we ended on this question
lost high on to that one we do do you
remember that I x minus one of my plus
one I'm doing that from Emory and then
the right spot at I swapped good ok
excellent cuz number mean awesome now if
you remember what I left you with was a
bit of a challenge I said what if I
changed this into this do you remember
that did anyone have a got it anyway
yeah ok now we got if you recall when
this is PI on 2 and this was a right
angle we got what kind of shape out of
that we've got a semicircle ok now if
you haven't done this why did you just
dumb don't write don't put this under
the new head and put this back on the
previous page maybe with the semicircle
let me show you what this thing's you
look like you might recall the much i'm
just gonna hijack this sum of the two of
you you might recall and what I had was
a set of points that all kind of did
this do you remember that and that's
what trace that semicircle yes so I was
thinking at the angled now here I yet
here this pile to was important because
it was the angle formed by those two
chords as it were on the circles you
remember that I can I think about this
if I've changed the paion to which we
use like alternate angles and parallel
lines to show that how to pilot in there
if I change all those angles up there to
PI on well for starters you're not going
to be able to say egg on the semicircle
because it's not a writing or any more
but you're going to have something
somewhat similar to this aren't you
you're going to have a whole bunch of
these it's just that they're going to be
pointy up do you agree cuz pilot for use
half the size now I can start to trace
some of this out i will show you some of
these points for instance if we put one
here and they even come here and we know
we could get this on this isosceles
triangle key on that one there
to it which pile on 4 820 our front yard
that means instead of sitting here by
learn what it what the coordinates
nothing what's the complex I'm on that's
our that's I internet whatever this
course I saw the imaginarium plan to do
point here I've got to go higher do you
agree with that so it might be might be
something like this I'm doing
importantly I'm going to plan for them
yes now I'm going to get other pie on
fours as well I'm going to get some over
here too because if I can have an angle
that's smaller than playing on to like
actually go plus just actually not that
exaggerated a bit we do now just have a
look just have a look at what I'm
tracing our how did you describe it what
kinds of geometric properties come to my
when you see a diagram like this Nathan
what are you thinking angles in the same
segment standing on the same arc of the
same core they subtend what is't end
again they sort n equal angles at the
circumference now what you have in the
first case this simple example is an
example of that right it's just that
happens to you exactly a right angle
which means that by the way if you had
like the opposite side of this shape
somebody asked me on why don't we get
that angle down the bottom needs to be
minus if you understand the bottom then
this is going to be a cyclic quad cycle
court and the thing you know about the
opposite angles of a cyclic quad is that
they add up to 180 degrees a
supplementary right well here right down
the middle 19 19 but here you've got a
small angle on this side so you got all
these pile fours oh yeah so you're still
tracing out an arc because you still
need this shape to be a segment do you
see that so we can work out we could do
some put an effort into work out with
the equation this is but I just won't
demonstrate the
is that circle is sort of like if you
split into like borders of just equal
clothes would it be three corners oh
that's a great question it's a really
good question and I'm going to let you
think about that you can do some
geometry here just like we did before
and try to work out do you remember we
drew that circle and I post your
question of like oh what's the the range
of the argument like how far and what's
the range of the modulus to remember
that okay we have to do some triangles
we have to construct some things on
there to work out how does the geometry
can you tell us what's going on there
isn't a trivial answer to that question
you have to do some work but you can
work it out just to close off let's just
suppose I can just apply to 250 for what
if I'd you just select whatever
something like 2 pi on three what would
you expect instead of this hmm by now
most of you have worked out okay well
you're going to get another arc of some
kind I've got an art you got an arc this
is still going to be an art but don't
tell me about this angle is to find
three you already told me the size of it
right it's in degrees 120 degrees okay
so what kind of Arc wouldn't trace out
it's going to trace out a flat one right
and that's on let's get another ecology
down here if you drew a low arc like
that right it's actually quite easy to
see you draw all of your angles if you
see how that's a nice wide angle that
one who can't read agrees I just made it
up but you get the idea right so it's
really important for you to be able to
look at this and then start to see
what's going on right see I mean by
extension to be that next level skill
you can't just simply sort of algebra
this out and then plot some points okay
you have to think in a much more
conceptual way to think about what kind
of shape are going to get out